well president Trump caused a bit of a
controversy yesterday kind of a change
of pace for him of course there was
there was deep concern on the left and
among among the media because he lent
his endorsement to the idea of Bible
literacy classes so in a tweet yesterday
he said numerous states introducing
Bible literacy classes giving students
the option of studying the Bible
starting to make a turn back great
now the I'm not sure starting to make a
turn back I guess I meant turn back to a
time when we studied the Bible either
way you know I agree it is great so the
concert the the laws that he's talking
about which which the media tells us are
controversial these laws which are being
advanced in a few states including
Kentucky is one of them a few other
states they would they would introduce
elective Bible classes in school that
kids that's elective means you choose go
you elect you don't have to take it you
could take if you wanted to and the
classes would teach the Bible in terms
of history and literature so obviously
students are not going to be required to
affirm any of the doctrines in the Bible
or to affirm its infallibility nor would
they be taught or forced to adopt accept
any of the moral prescriptions in the
Bible or any of the or or will they have
to accept any of the supernatural claims
in the Bible so that that's in a public
school setting that's obviously not how
the Bible is going to be taught and I
think we all agree that it should not be
taught that way and Christians most of
all I think would not want the Bible
taught that way in a public school
setting and I'll get more to that a
little bit later on but the Bible would
be presented as a literary work and its
historical context and its impact on
history would be examined that's the
idea now why is this a controversial
idea
well there's for no good reason the
reason why it's a controversial idea is
that we live in a very very stupid
culture filled with nincompoops who
think that where it says in the First
Amendment Congress shall make no law
respecting an establishment of religion
they think that means that schools have
to ignore the very existence of religion
they think actually they think that that
every public institution every public
person anyone in the public square
everyone has to ignore the existence of
religion and the public square has to
exist as if religion does not exist and
and that's what they think that that
phrase in the or that clause in the
First Amendment means that's not what it
means
Congress shall make no law respecting an
establishment of religion what that
means is is there's no way for me to
really explain what it means without
just repeating it but what it means is
that Congress which is a legislative
body cannot write a piece of legislation
which would then become law which would
force anyone to accept any particular
religion so that's what it means
Congress cannot make a law forcing you
to accept or adopt any religion that's
that's what the first amendment is
trying to tell us that's got nothing at
all to do with teaching the Bible in
public school because you teach the
Bible in public school first of all
that's not Congress second there's no
law being passed third no one is being
forced to accept any religion whatsoever
so so it's got nothing to do with what
the First Amendment says and the thing
is you can't really have a well-rounded
education if it's divorced entirely from
the Bible it's just not possible it
really is impossible to have a
well-rounded a real and well-rounded
education in America if you're just
going to ignore the existence of the
Bible you can't do it because no matter
what you believe or what God if any you
worship the simple fact is this that the
Bible is the most influential important
book ever composed it is the most
translated the best-selling the most
widely read the most quoted the most
debated the most cherished the most
loved the most hated the most debated
over I already said that one it is the
most everything basically is this book
this book more than any other book
that's ever been written or composed or
compiled has molded the world in which
we live especially in the West so if you
rip it out of education you are going to
leave a Bible shaped hole behind which
cannot really be plugged in with
anything so just to just to break it
down a little bit you cannot begin to
appreciate the works of say Shakespeare
or Tolstoy or Dostoyevsky or Dickens or
Dante or pretty much any Faulkner I mean
any great novel or play or poem that's
been written in the West anytime between
like the 1st and 20th centuries if you
want to appreciate them and fully
understand what they're saying and what
they're doing you have to know something
about the Bible I mean the idea that we
could teach kids about Shakespeare
without without them understanding the
biblical themes that are dripping all
over Shakespeare's works it's just it's
just it's impossible you would be
hard-pressed to think of a great piece
of writing that was written from about
the Year 90 to maybe the year 1900 that
was not to some degree influenced by old
or New Testament texts and obviously the
New Testament didn't exist in the Year
90 South so I'm saying you know older
New Testament texts pretty much any
great piece of writing it would be very
difficult to find one that is not in
some way influenced and a lot of it was
heavily influenced by the Bible you're
going to have also a difficult time
comprehending or appreciating
Renaissance art I mean I don't see how
you could take the Renaissance art out
of schools obviously kids are gonna
learn about that how you supposed to
know anything about that if you all of
it depicts biblical scenes so how could
you possibly teach that without teaching
them about the Bible stories that they
that they depict so what do you do
you're gonna show them an image of the
sistine the the you know painting on the
ceiling of Sistine Chapel
and say yeah it's just that you know
those are just nobody knows what that is
those are just random you know people
flying around though and we don't really
know you know you'll have to go home and
ask your parents what that's all about
but we're just gonna show you that's
what it is right just doesn't make any
sense you know Western philosophy the
Enlightenment the Reformation all of
these the abolition of slavery all of
these historical events again are
dripping with with biblical influence
and then also how are you going to give
people an appreciation of the
biographies of guys like Martin Luther
King jr. or Abraham Lincoln or Magellan
or Columbus or even Gandhi who read the
Sermon on the Mount every day reportedly
how are you gonna do that if you don't
have a handle on the Bible because
that's what drove these men largely now
I'm fully aware as I'm saying this that
many of these topics are being
increasingly ignored in our public
school system and and look if we've
simply given up on offering kids a real
education and if we're now unconcerned
with silly little subjects like history
and literature and philosophy and art
then then yeah I guess the whole
biblical literacy concept is is kind of
irrelevant biblical literacy is
necessary for general literacy in many
of the subjects I just mentioned but if
we're throwing those subjects out then
it's a moot point I suppose but in that
case we've just tossed out education and
there's no point of view what's what's
even the point anymore of sending kids
to school if our educational facilities
are going to actually try to you know
educate then the Bible must necessarily
be a bedrock of that F not the only
bedrock not the only thing but it
obviously has to be a crucial part of
that effort to understand these things
now a couple of other points some people
will say that yeah sure we should teach
them the Bible so let's have kids learn
about the Bible and and let's have it as
part of the world's religion class and
we could teach it alongside and give it
equal time to say the Koran
and the Gita and and I don't know that's
a bettin book of the dead right now I
completely agree that we should teach
kids about those texts as well we should
teach kids about those religions you
can't very well learn much about the Far
East if you if you don't know something
about Buddhism you can't learn anything
about the Middle East from about the
Year 600 till now if you don't know
something about the Quran you obviously
can't learn anything about about India
if you don't know something about
Hinduism and the bhagavad-gita and those
kinds of works and we do obviously want
to teach kids about those other parts of
the world those other cultures but it's
not the same you know the idea that we
should give those texts equal time to
the Bible is obviously absurd because
none of them come close to influencing
Western art and literature and
philosophy that is the civilization we
actually live in and that's the kids
need to get a handle on their own
civilization first because this is where
we live and then you can move on to
study those other civil but as far as
this war is everything that's around us
all of that has been to some degree
influenced by the Bible
whereas I mean you can learn about many
of those subjects without without ever
picking up the bag of odd Gita and you
know you you can learn everything you
need to know about Shakespeare without
knowing anything about Hinduism one
other point as I mentioned that actually
I think the only people who could make a
feasible logical case against teaching
the Bible in public schools ironically
would be Christians and I've heard some
Christians say this over the last couple
of days they said that you know I I
don't actually want this public schools
teaching anything about the Bible
because um because well obviously I
wouldn't want them teaching the theology
of the Bible I'm not I wouldn't trust a
public school teacher I wouldn't trust
some random history teacher to teach
theology which they're not going to do
but then at the same time I don't really
want the Bible being taught as a purely
literary piece of work because that
could be confusing for my kids or a
Christian we're teaching them that this
is that this is the Word of God then
they're gonna go school and learn that
it's a piece of literature so so that's
the only objection that to me could make
any sense whatsoever
from a secular perspective there's
there's just no objection that makes
sense obviously from a secular
perspective fine you see the Bible as a
piece of literature
you can't factually deny its influence
and importance even if you hate it so
clearly it needs to be taught in schools
but the concern from a Christian
perspective of teaching a Bible as
literature when you're also trying to
teach as the Word of God I understand
that concern and and that could get a
little bit dicey to have somebody
teaching the Bible who really doesn't
think that if there's anything
spiritually significant about it and
it's just teaching it as and then what
do you do maybe they're teaching Exodus
the story of X is again very influential
story which you can see those themes
repeated and echoed in many other pieces
of literature and pieces of art and so
on so you Dean do need the kids to
understand that story but what if you've
got a teacher teaching Exodus who's
gonna tell the kids hey by the way this
never happened Moses didn't exist this
is just a story it's a fable whatever so
that is a that's so that could be a
problem but the fact all we're just
dealing with us a simple fact here that
if you're going to give kids a
well-rounded education that touches on
philosophy literature art and all of
that they need they need to be taught
the Bible as well the Bible needs to be
part of that you just can't separate it
from it and if you're saying well I
don't trust the public schools to deal
with that well then maybe that's just a
good indication that you shouldn't be
sending your kid the public school
that's all I could say about that all
right
quickly the the former mayor of San
Francisco Willie Brown wrote what I
guess we will call a column in the San
Francisco Chronicle and this is what he
had to say he said I've been peppered
with calls from the national media about
my relationship with Kamala Harris
particularly since it became obvious
that she was going to run for president
most of them I have not returned yes yes
we dated it was more than 20 years ago
yes I may have influenced her career by
pointing her to two state committees
when I was Assembly Speaker the and I
certainly helped with her first race for
District Attorney on San Francisco I've
also helped the careers of House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi
gavin newsom Diane Feinstein and a host
of other politicians the difference is
that Harris is the only one who after I
helped her sent word that I would be
indicted if I so much as jaywalked quote
unquote while she was DEA now by the way
um this story has gotten like no
attention whatsoever even though you've
got a guy admitting that he dated Kamala
Harris and helped her get her first
steps into politics now when we say
dated what he means is had an affair
with he was married at the time maybe
his wife was estranged or whatever but
still he was married so this was an
affair he had an affair you had a fair
with Camille Harris and so Harris slept
with a married man and used that
relationship to get a step up in
politics again you would think that that
would be a significant story you've got
this guy admitting to this Camille
Harris pretends to be a champion for
women but according to to to Willie
Brown she's a champion for women I guess
except for the woman whose husband she
slept with in order to get ahead in
politics so and of course when we're
talking about the character of Camilla
Harris this is the same person who as
Attorney General of California
collaborated with Planned Parenthood to
prosecute the undercover journalists who
exposed its sale of baby parts so
Camille Harris has been in the pocket
she's been a minion of the abortion
industry for a very long time and even
that what the way that she you know as
someone who has accepted so much money
from the abortion industry and then she
comes to their defense you know that's a
story that you think should have gotten
a lot of attention which of course it
wasn't going to because it deals with
the abortion industry and now we have
this and people are just kind of yawning
which doesn't make any sense to me so
for me they're obviously I wouldn't be
tempted to support Camilla Harris anyway
so there are a lot of reasons not to
support her
I think that maybe this would be one of
them all right let's check with CNBC
which ran an article a few days ago
titled here's how much money you save
when you don't have kids so this is just
another propaganda piece trying to
convince people of the benefits of dying
alone let's look at it it says in part
your friends may tell you having kids
has made them happier they're probably
lying
research shows that Parenthood leads to
a happiness gap maybe that's because the
pleasures of parenthood are outweighed
by all the extra responsibilities
housework and of course the costs and
then later on it gets to the supposed
costs of having kids it says the average
middle-income married couple spent
between twelve thousand three hundred
fifty dollars and thirteen thousand nine
hundred dollars on each of their
children in 2015
extrapolating from that number and
you're looking at spending two hundred
and thirty three thousand six hundred
and ten dollars per child from birth
through age 17 higher income families
will spend around three hundred and
seventy thousand dollars supposedly and
then it just goes on from there
now first of all these numbers are
completely insane and the media loves to
do this I mean you see these stories
every every couple of months you have
one of these stories about here's how
much it costs to have kids $14,000 per
year per kid 14 grand per kid now I have
three kids that means according to these
numbers we're spending forty thousand
dollars on just our kids which is which
is completely believable it makes sense
if you're buying your kids a brand-new
wardrobe of designer clothing every week
and if you're eating out for every
single meal and if you buy a new car
every year and it basically if you're
about as wasteful as humanly possible
that I can see maybe spending 14 grand
per kid per year
and a quarter of a million dollars on
one kid through through their entire
childhood which means that if you have
like four kids
that's a million bucks right
that you're going to be spending but if
you actually exercise even a small
amount of financial discipline then it
will be much much cheaper and we don't
spend anyone close to that per kid I
don't even do we even spend a 14,000 on
all three kids combined that to me seems
doubtful our you know our grocery bill
is a little bit higher than it would be
if we were just the two of us but but
the point is if you actually make if you
if you actually I don't know cook meals
with with with ingredients then it's
it's it's not nearly as expensive as you
think and if you're not dead set on
getting your kids brand-new fancy
brand-name clothes all the time if
you're okay with like hand-me-downs
you know I weave my oldest son now we're
passing his clothes on to to our
youngest son so we really have no new
clothing costs for for our youngest son
so numbers like this would assume that
with our youngest son we're just going
to throw out all the old clothes and go
get him new clothes which would be an
incredibly stupid and insane thing to do
what to get to just so you understand if
you don't have kids or anything and you
see numbers like this and you and you're
scared by them you think well you know I
have to be like a freakin millionaire to
have kids well yeah that's what the
media wants you to believe because
they're trying to convince you there are
people in the media who are just
desperate to convince everyone that they
shouldn't have kids and I think because
a lot of that now the person who wrote
this article I have no idea if they have
kids or not but I think a lot of the
people who are behind this propaganda
they themselves don't have kids they've
made that decision in life so they're
trying to convince other people to join
them in their loneliness but all I'm
saying is is is don't do that at least
if you're gonna make the decision not to
have kids don't make it based on this
because I get look I I know I know
families that have six or six seven
eight kids and according to these
numbers that means that they'd they
would be spending over a hundred grand a
year just on their kids but some of
these families I know that have these
big a lot of kids they
even make a hundred grand a year so
according to these numbers it's that's
impossible like how are they surviving
but then you look at these family not
only they surviving but they're thriving
they're not living in rags in the gutter
I mean they have homes if they have
their food I mean everyone is perfectly
well-fed perfectly happy well-adjusted
families that have a lot of kids and
somehow find a way to pay for it on you
know on a not even six-figure income
which again according to the media
should be impossible but it's not
impossible is the point but the you know
the more fundamental issue here is this
whole idea that you should be making
these kinds of decisions based on these
sorts of financial considerations which
which you really shouldn't be now I'm
not saying that you should you know you
shouldn't take the finances into account
at all but if you feel called to start a
family and you really want to start a
family then then do it yeah I mean it
might be you might have to make some
sacrifices you know you might have to
give up a few vacations here and there
and you know you maybe you won't won't
be living with exactly the same sort of
luxury you would be living with living
with otherwise but but that's not the
the main point the main point of life
isn't just to save money now I hate to I
hate to be reduced to cliches here but
you can't take it with you and if you
don't have kids you don't even have
anyone to pass your money down to so
look what's the point so you you don't
have kids because you want to save money
and then you save a whole bunch of money
and you die and then so what what good
does it you don't even have anyone to
bequeath it to so it's just completely
pointless all right finally I want to
answer cuz we don't have a chef to do a
couple we're running out of time here
but if you want to send a message an
email to the show Matt wall show at
gmail.com Matt wall show at gmail.com a
couple of quick emails from Cody
says hey Matt I recently listen to your
show where you talked about Elizabeth
Warren and her ultra-rich tax I loved
what you said and I thought I'd offer a
bit of insight into some other relevant
discourse and get your opinion on it a
lot of people talking about this issue
will claim that it is immoral for
billionaires to have that much money and
as an economist that strikes me as odd
it certainly rubs me the wrong way
however when people claim it's immoral
because the billionaires do it quote on
the backs of exploited workers for the
majority of corporations and businesses
and firms this is impossible because of
how corporate production works
production is a combination of labor and
capital and firms will only hire labor
or by slash rent capital until the
benefit I II increased revenue from
increased output out matches the cost
wages for laborers and rent investment
for capital this makes it impossible for
firms to make any profit off of workers
because the amount they're paying all
their workers is always equal liberated
to the revenue they get so they don't
get any profit from that the profits for
a firm usually come from owning the
capital they use instead of renting it
and thus paying themselves the rent they
would normally get thank you for that
Cody is adding some extra context and
insight and here's what I find this is
just anecdotally but when we have these
kinds of discussions the people who are
on the more socialist side of it and say
oh it's you know making money off the
backs of exploited workers and we got to
redistribute the wealth I very rarely
hear from someone with that opinion who
has the kind of knowledge about the
subject that Cody clearly has so it's
just it's odd to me right that all of it
and if you're on the socialist side that
should concern you that all of the
really knowledgeable people who really
know how business works and can write an
email like that almost all of them seem
to be on the free-market side from
trevor he says Matt I'm a fan of your
show and would like to thank you for
your insights on your Monday show you
mentioned that you didn't go to college
if you would be willing to tell if you
would be willing could you tell a bit of
the story of yourself education and how
you got into political commentary it was
just a bit surprising to me that you
didn't have a higher education thanks
for all you do and Godspeed
trevor i won't go
my whole autobiography because I think
it'll be terribly terribly boring and
irrelevant I'll just say that in terms
of education I discovered that it was
possible to learn quite a bit just by
reading books and to a lesser extent
through the internet as well which can
be a great tool for learning if you know
how to use it and you're responsible and
using it so I discovered that not only
could I learn that way but actually for
me it was the best way to learn because
not everybody excels in the kind of
formal environment of an educational
institution some people need a sort of
freer and looser approach to it or a
self-guided approach to education I
guess is the best the best way to phrase
it that's what I discovered was the case
for me in fact I discovered that when I
was in still in grade school and I
realized that this kind of sitting down
having someone regurgitate information
and I have to regurgitate it onto a
sheet of paper to show that I've picked
on but it's very it's very focused on
memorization and you're only learning
about this subject for a certain amount
of time and then you got to move on to
this subject and everything and just
that whole there are some people who
excel in that environment and do very
well in it but there are also some
people who just don't and it's not
because they're stupid it's not because
they can't learn it's just because they
learn differently and I knew that that's
the case I mean that certainly is the
case for me the way that I tend to learn
is I get very obsessed with one
particular subject and I read all about
it so the only thing I want to read
about or talk about or think about for
weeks or months or or longer and so I
just dive into I learn everything I can
about that subject and then some other
subject will strike my fancy and I'll
dive into that and learn everything I
can about that and I'll learn it through
different ways I'll read books I'll
watch documentaries I'll listen to
audiobooks I'll read essays and articles
and stuff so you just if you're going to
school again in a more formal education
environment you can't really learn that
way but outside of school you can so
that's why I say to people
and I sound like a broken record but
before you go to college before you sign
on that dotted line and sign up for all
of that debt you should know something
about not only what you want to do with
your life and what your passions are and
what your interests are but also you
should know something about how you
learn and if learning this way is
actually beneficial or even possible for
you because if it's not that doesn't
mean that you're not going to know that
you're gonna decide not to go to college
and you're gonna end up being stupid and
illiterate and lacking in knowledge and
information no it just means that maybe
you go and learn some other way
finally let's say I'll read I read one
more Audrey says Matt you recently
talked about the whole PETA thing with
them pretending to be cooking a dog or
whatever and I thought I would share
some of my views on the matter as a
student studying animal science the
reason why eating dogs is seen as
different from eating sheeps or pigs is
mainly because of differences in
domestication dogs were domesticated to
20,000 years ago and as we've evolved
they have evolved alongside us as
companions and protectors livestock were
domesticated for food they've evolved to
be the most efficient and giving us what
we want from them like milk or meat or
whatever produced it is dogs and
livestock have served different purposes
for thousands of years and will continue
to serve different purposes probably
forever another big reason why people
don't want to eat dog meat and this one
sucks is because it's a common belief in
Asia that tortured dog meat tastes
better people in Asia will actually burn
dogs and skin them alive
there's even an annual festival the
Yulin festival in China where over
10,000 dogs are tortured and killed in
contrast in the United States we try our
hardest to make sure that livestock have
the best life possible and are killed in
the most humane way possible if we were
going to slaughter dogs for food in the
u.s. at least we would have the good
feeling that they weren't skinned alive
so if anyone in a foreign country serves
you Fido lasagna
maybe politely decline Audrey this
rarely happens but you have convinced me
and you've changed my mind I think that
my position on eating dog meat which
again I said I would never do here but
if I went to a foreign country and it
was in it if they
serve me you know a a Rex stir-fry you
know a Clifford the Big Red Dog stir-fry
if they served it to me and in a foreign
cut I would eat it to be polite and also
maybe a little bit out of curiosity but
with that extra context I think I would
have to say no I'll pass
I think I'll just have a salad please so
thank you for that and thanks everyone
for your emails I'll talk to you
tomorrow
Godspeed